الرئيس ترامب متحديًا الضربة
التي قتلت روني عمومًا قاسم
سليماني ، لقد أرسلنا رسالة قوية
إلى الإرهابيين إذا كنت تقدر
حياتك فلن تهدد
حياة شعبنا على الرغم من أن البعض يدعم
قرار الرئيس والبعض الآخر لا يوافق على
تنظيم عشرات الاحتجاجات الحربية
في جميع أنحاء البلاد يوم الخميس ، ظهر
تأثير تموج ضربات الطائرات بدون طيار بشكل خاص
في فورت براغ بولاية نورث كارولينا ، حيث تم نشر أكثر من
4000 من أعضاء الفرقة 82 المحمولة جواً
في الشرق الأوسط
كتعزيزات ومثل الحرية ،
فإن لها ثمنًا وجنودنا
هم من يدفعون مقابل الإضراب.  تم
الشعور أيضًا من الناحية التكنولوجية بأن بعض
المخادعين يرسلون نصوصًا مزيفة
تخبر الأفراد أنه تمت
صياغة خادم نظام الخدمة الانتقائية في الولايات المتحدة
قبل إصدار تنبيه
بشأن الاحتيال ويمكن للتدخل
أن ينشر شركة أمان الشبكة
CloudFlare وتقول محاولات القرصنة الإيرانية
ضد الولايات المتحدة  تضاعف ثلاث مرات تقريبًا منذ
رد سليماني مرة أخرى  واشنطن العاصمة - يتبنى مجلس
النواب تشريعات من شأنها
أن تقلل من قدرة الرئيس ترامب
على اتخاذ إجراء عسكري ضد الكونجرس الإيراني ،
وقد حاول على مدى عقود أن يكون
له كلا الطريقتين الذي يريده ، حيث يريد
حرية انتقاد القرارات التي
يتخذها القائد العام لكنهم لا يفعلون ذلك.
يريدون مسؤولية اتخاذ
تلك القرارات بدلاً
من القائد العام ، أنا جون لورانس